could there be a storybook ending for
Gwen Stefani and Blake show you know
that is the question everybody's talking
about comes those two - well here what
one has to say about that but it's
another partnership that has Gwen
feeling hella good right now like hoping
that by saying it out loud that it will
actually become real for me but that
you're pregnant I'm gonna be doing my
first ever Vegas residency he's only a
good friend like Ellen would go there
but Gwen with her hands still shaking
announcer up coming just a girl
residency it kicks off June 27th to
Planet Hollywood Zappos Theatre Gwen
says this is beyond her wildest dreams
sometimes I just feel like I'm in a
dream because when it comes to like just
being able to fulfill some of my
fantasies our et sir says boyfriend
Blake Shelton encouraged her to take the
lucrative Sin City deal flying a
Hollywood resident artists like JLo and
Brittany have reportedly earned at least
$300,000 each performance our source
says Gwen's three sons with ex Gavin
Rossdale are on board and during her
appearance Gwen sure made it sound like
the ball is in Blake's court when it
comes to getting engaged
[Music]
I do I think about it all the time yeah
and does he think about it I swear
what do you feel about it I think you
should get married really
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]